ahora hay una prueba una prueba del
famosísimo teorema de pitágoras esta
prueba existe gracias al matemático
indio del siglo 20 bàscara y lo que
haremos es iniciar con un cuadrado
entonces voy a dibujar un cuadrado y lo
voy a dibujar un poco levantado como
puedes ver así un poco levantado al
cuadrado entonces bueno a vasca no se
sabe si saben muy poco sobre él en
realidad no se sabe mucho se sabe que su
papá era un astrónomo y bueno ok ahora
ya tenemos aquí el cuadrado el mejor
intento de dibujarlo como es un cuadrado
cada uno de sus de sus vértices forma un
ángulo recto y la longitud de cada uno
de sus lados es se digamos que ese
entonces bueno lo que voy a hacer es
construir cuatro triángulos dentro de
este cuadrado y ok entonces desde
primero desde este vértice bajó de
manera vertical
bajo una línea dibuja una línea vertical
y después de este vértice una línea
horizontal dado que una es vertical y la
otra es totalmente horizontal a ella ahí
se forma un ángulo recto
ahora de este vértice voy otra vez
dibujo una línea de manera vertical y
aquí se va a formar un ángulo recto
entre estas dos y después de este
vértice dibujo otra línea horizontal y
aquí se forman ángulos rectos aquí
tenemos un ángulo recto y también acá
tenemos un ángulo recto hemos construido
y cuadrado y dentro de él cuatro
triángulos rectángulos en medio parece
ser que se forma me lo lo mínimo que
parece es un rectángulo o posiblemente
un cuadrado no hemos demostrado que es
un cuadrado pero ahora pensemos en estos
triángulos y si son congruentes en
definitiva todos tienen la misma
longitud si en la hipotenusa la
hipotenusa mide lo mismo para todos los
triángulos entonces bueno lala la
hipotenusa es el lado opuesto al ángulo
recto entonces todos esos lados miden
ser si podemos mostrar que todos los
ángulos correspondientes miden lo mismo
sabemos que son triángulos congruentes
así que vamos a hacer eso si tenemos los
triángulos y tenemos que sus ángulos
miden lo mismo y un lado mide lo mismo
todos entonces son congruentes de hecho
podemos mostrar los asumimos que este
ángulo mide teta entonces este ángulo
debe medir 90 menos teta porque son
ángulos son ángulos complementarios
forman un ángulo recto y si este ángulo
mide 90 menos 30 sabemos que este ángulo
y éste deben deben sumar sumar 90 grados
porque no nos queda un ángulo recto
entonces entonces este ángulo mide teta
este mide teta y este después también
debe medir 90 menos teta
entonces este ángulo me detecta y este
ángulo 90 menos teta este ángulo teta y
al fin bueno finalmente este 90 menos de
está ahora podemos ver que estos que en
estos cuatro triángulos los tres ángulos
que se forman son teta
90 menos 30 y 90 grados tienen tienen
los mismos ángulos así que en lo mínimo
en los mínimos son triángulos similares
pero sus hipotecas miden lo mismo por lo
tanto los cuatro triángulos son
completamente triángulos congruentes
con eso vamos a asumir que el cateto más
largo de estos triángulos estos catetos
el azul que estoy aquí el cateto más
largo de cada uno de los triángulos
supongamos que tiene longitud b así que
esta longitud esta longitud es b y vamos
a asumir que el cateto más pequeño estas
distancias esta distancia esta distancia
están esas ahí está también está esa
esas longitud bueno esa longitud es a
entonces vamos a asumir eso esa longitud
es
ahora ya con esto vamos a hacer algo
algo algo interesante primero que todo
lo que vamos a pensar primero antes que
todo en el área de este cuadrado cuál es
el área de este cuadrado en términos de
c sale directo porque porque es un
cuadrado de lados cada uno de sus lados
me deseen entonces entonces su área es
igual a c al cuadrado ahora lo que haría
construirla a continuación es acomodar
estos triángulos
y la figura que se forme ponerla en
términos de acidez y con eso espero y
anhelo con todo mi corazón que nos lleve
al teorema de pitágoras ahora lo que voy
a hacer es copiar y pegar esto esta
figura este diagrama que hicimos lo voy
a copiar y pegar porque nos va a ayudar
esto nos va ayudar para lo que vamos a
hacer a continuación que está bastante
interesante entonces entonces lo que
hago es es poner esta figura acá y voy a
borrar voy a quitar esto entonces lo que
voy a hacer y aquí viene lo divertido lo
que voy a hacer a continuación es voy a
mover este triángulo y lo voy a poner
acá de este lado entonces lo que quiero
hacer aquí es voy a intentar copiar y
pegar ahí no así no voy a intentar aquí
copiar y pegar este este triángulo
ojalá funcione
ahí está ok ahora lo voy a mover para
acá y aquí lo acomodó como lo dije ahí
está ok perfecto ok
muy bien entonces te gusto me da aquí
aquí voy a aquí faltan las líneas para
dejar en claro que que ahí sigue el
cuadrado y también el cateto el cateto
pequeño y aquí está ok entonces qué fue
lo que hice lo que hice fue mover mover
este triángulo hacia acá ajá
ahora lo que voy a hacer lo que ahora
voy a hacer es mover el triángulo que
está arriba a esta parte inferior y
solamente estoy re acomodando la misma
área algo lo mismo simplemente es la
misma área porque es la misma figura
simplemente estoy moviendo las partes
ajá pero es lo mismo es simplemente
estoy moviendo las partes esto lo voy a
copiar y pegar acá abajo ahí está ok
perfecto y le falta la base vea este
triángulo aquí
ok perfecto
es este triángulo este triángulo es este
triángulo simplemente lo moví del lugar
y este triángulo este es este triángulo
el centro el centro es el cuadrado de
siempre no no lo hicimos cosa alguna es
este este cuadrado es este cuadrado y
ahora me pregunta para ti es la
siguiente cómo podemos expresar el área
de esta nueva figura la cual cabe
mencionar nuevamente que es la misma
área no simplemente se movieron las
partes de la figura pero cómo podemos
expresarla en términos de así debes en
sí en sí la clave es reconocer la
longitud de la base de esta figura esto
este lado de abajo cuánto mide esa es la
clave de todo esto es la magia entonces
la longitud de todo esto de este lado es
b y de este lado está entonces el total
es simplemente a + b
y eso eso por sí solo me parece bastante
interesante pero hay algo más en esto
que es más interesante esta longitud ok
esta longitud es a esta misma cierto
entonces esto mi idea y podemos
construir aquí un cuadrado de la 2a por
ahí entonces tenemos aquí un cuadrado
este cuadrado de área ahora voy a
intentar ponerlo en un color que se mire
que se vea bien entonces este cuadrado
tiene tiene área al cuadrado ahora cuál
es el área de lo que resta de lo que
sobra de la figura si estas longitudes a
esto también me de esto mide a más bien
total cierto entonces simplemente le
vamos a restar el an y nos queda de esto
esto mi deber y entonces ok entonces lo
lo lo que resta de la figura aquí nos
queda un cuadrado un cuadrado de lados b
x p así que todo esto que estoy
coloreando
esto es un cuadrado de área v al
cuadrado y el total entonces el área
total sería al cuadrado más b al
cuadrado es igual a ese al cuadrado
porque la otra figura tiene área sea al
cuadrado y este simplemente es la misma
simplemente reacomodamos las piezas así
que qué suerte ahora bàscara guau qué
hermosa y divertida demostración nos
brindó del teorema de pitágoras gracias
bàscara donde quiera que estés